i remember this really painful [ __ ]
cringe thing i did right right i was at
the an ax party right yeah
you know i was chilling and you know
it's where you kind of bump into people
that you somewhat recognize or maybe you
know them you've searched them once you
know you go over and say hi and stuff
i was at this party and there was a
group of people like maybe like
five
uh content creators influencers whatever
you wanna call yeah uh that i didn't
really know but there's one person who i
saw them and i was like oh i i know that
person i spoke to them in the uk so i
went over to go say hi right and i was
like oh hi and i see you how are you
doing we like we hung out in the uk uh
turns out it wasn't that person i had
mistaken them and i thought it was
and then [ __ ] you know this [ __ ] even
this i'd never like been [ __ ] i i
hadn't even drank that much it was like
i had two drinks just got it yeah yeah
yeah like one one or two drinks yeah and
i'd even though i like wasn't drunk at
all i i somehow sobered up even though i
hadn't right now i'm
uh well yeah sorry about that um
i was like yeah i know you and stuff you
and she's like that's not me and i'm
like oh i'm like because i you really
look like this person i really
really thought you were this person and
i was like okay i could have i could
have maybe i could have maybe died on
this sword and get out my phone look
you look really like this but no it
wasn't and uh yeah it was a really
awkward thing where i was like oh
that's really embarrassing i'm really
sorry about that yeah you guys have a
good time yeah ignore me and then i
walked away really awkwardly like why
am i so cringe
i mean i'm sure uh have you have you
like met fans who have kind of been like
that as well like yeah i don't care i'm
indifferent towards it but i know i mean
i guess that's how they feel right yeah
yeah i guess when it's other it was like
five content creators it's like great
now they're all gonna think i'm like
this [ __ ] weirdo who just approaches
people and girls are you this person
it's me it's me look
i think i have like like my i'm blind
and then when i got when i when i went
home whatever and i i followed that so
was it another content creator or was it
it was another content okay
okay you happen to be in like the same
field and stuff as well and it was also
really awkward because uh you know i'm
sure they uh they they recently followed
me on twitter and i wonder if they
remember me going up to them like three
years ago yeah i if i ever meet them i'm
gonna ask them again if they remember my
my favorite interaction of that that's
kind of similar i was on the opposite
end though was uh in singapore afa when
i went with god
and uh there was this one moment i
couldn't i'll never [ __ ] forget i'm
sorry if you watch this show but uh some
like this guy i was walking with gone
and alan and sydney through the
convention hall yeah because i was on my
way to something and this dude just like
like spots me from across the hallway
right and he's like looking me dead in
the [ __ ] eyes all right so i'm like
oh he clearly knows me right yeah i just
kind of you know just waved to him or
whatever and he came up to me and he was
like oh my god are you gigging
i remember that crowd i was standing
right behind you and imagine me
imagine me this kid so [ __ ] excited
right saying calling me gig and me
having to go
no but he is
i remember thinking i don't even know
how to feel about this you know there
was there was a split second where i'm
like this is a bit right but like this
is a joke
i'm just like should i be happy or
offended i'm not sure but i kind of feel
both right now happy that obviously
someone you know someone recognized me
but someone knows me uh but i'm happy
that's i was literally standing right
here and they go to joey and goes i love
you all joey i love you i love your
videos
love your videos
i love those anime minutes
i was like yeah
again at first i thought it was like
kind of just like a joke right being
like oh i'll just say it's joey hahaha
funny and you know i was waiting for him
to be like no i'm just kidding and then
actually turn towards god yeah but he at
the moment i kind of pointed to god and
he looked at god and just his smile just
dropped
like like he was like oh god i have made
a horrible mistake
i am so sorry to the boat i mean he knew
he still knew me though but yeah i guess
he just mixed me and god's user names up
yeah you might have just said yeah yeah
he was a nice kid so whatever but it was
one of the funniest interactions i've
seen
just experience well have you ever had
that point where you you're talking to
you talk to a fan or something and they
said oh i loved when you did x video and
you think to yourself i didn't do that
video i didn't do that video no my
favorite my favorite is when they're
like
sometimes
i do if we're like having more than a
five minute conversation i didn't make
that video but sometimes they just like
they just say this one comment and they
they leave and i'm just like
i won't ruin their day yeah
i don't want to i don't want to think
they messed up yeah i don't care i don't
want you
my favorite for those that i never have
the heart to tell them is when they're i
guess they're like really trying to sell
you on the point that they've been a fan
for a really long time and they're like
oh joey i [ __ ] love your stuff man
i've been watching you since 2010 man
like it's it's great i'm like alright
bye and then in the back of my head i'm
like i started in 2013. yeah yeah
i don't i don't really have the heart i
was in high school
in 2010 so it would be scary if you knew
me back then jesus christ but i don't
have the heart to tell i don't want to
be that guy right to be like a fake fan
you know i don't want to do that to them
i don't know if i've told this story i
know i've told you guys this story i
don't know if i said on the podcast
right right it was the it was the meetup
i did at uh uh with book walker at ax
right where i just signed and took
pictures oh yeah yeah yeah yeah sydney
got like his step yeah yeah yeah
and the line was pretty long i was very
i was very happy with myself i was like
wow people actually want to come and
hang out with me yeah yeah yeah
um you know and this i don't know how
long the line took maybe like 30 minutes
i don't know i don't know how i think it
was capped i think we all capped at like
an hour right yeah yeah so yeah it was
like like that whatever 30 minutes and
uh i'm i'm doing that and uh like one
guy comes up to me and i'm like holy
[ __ ] like there's a guy here
so i appreciate it i was like oh thanks
man and so i'm like yo hi how you doing
man he's like i'm good i'm good i'm good
and then we take a photo and he's like
yeah man uh could you sign this goblin
slayer book i really like the work you
did on it and i was like
i was like coming in he's like are you
not the author for goblins
and i was like
no
i was like
oh but i thought this was like a goblin
slayer boost like
no
no this is i'm a youtuber
and i'm
in my head i was like i was like did
this guy like look at the name yeah
i don't know who the author of goblin
slayer is but i'm guessing it doesn't
look like a connor sorry i think his
name is
so it's very different i don't know
maybe maybe this guy was like i i do not
judge i hear yeah
i do not see racism
maybe maybe a white guy from wales could
have you know written written a light
novel like damn this boy is very
hungover that's the case holy [ __ ] it's
so bad for this kid because you know i
didn't i didn't care that he confused me
but this guy looks so embarrassed
and his face he had never seen a face
drop that fast
because we've taken the photo and [ __ ]
too on his phone and i'm like you can go
ahead and delete that i won't i won't be
mad yeah yeah yeah i signed this thing
as well yeah i signed his goblin slayer
book and then he tells me he loved my
work on goblin style what was that the
goblin or something
yeah i didn't know what i did on goblin
slayer i don't know if i should be an
offender
because i i remember i remember like i
remember having this one conversation
once with a fan you know sometimes you
get into like pretty intense
conversation with fans about some of
your videos or something when you know
when you get when you have the time to
so i remember this one fan at like i
think it was like ax or one of the anime
conventions and we got we got into this
conversation about bleach right
and at this point i've said my takes
about bleach a lot whether on my videos
my first video was a bleach video in
other videos and um and podcast what are
you doing
huh did you say it was just okay i mean
i i uh i've i've i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna open that box of worms right now
but like i remember
i'm not going to open that kind of one
right now but i remember we're having
this like this [ __ ] intense
conversation about bleach and he kept
saying things like i remember when you
said this about the mundo arc and uh and
like this about tita kubo like like can
you like expand on that because like i
don't agree with this and we're like
having this full debate about this right
and i remember thinking i don't remember
saying this about bleach but i might
have said that about bleach so i'm just
going to entertain the idea right right
of this argument he's like of this
debate that he's having about me and so
we go into this like 10 minute [ __ ]
debate about bleach right and then at
the end i'm just like
yeah i finally understand your fall of
bleach video now and i'm just like
that was john's video
and at that point i just i just i didn't
even have the heart to tell him because
i was like we've been talking about a
video that i didn't make for 10 [ __ ]
minutes
and having a strong debate about it
how did he not realize that your voice
and john's voice is like completely
different
how did i not realize that he was
talking about a video that i didn't make
because the thing is i've talked so much
[ __ ] about bleach i'm just like that
sounds like something i might have said
i've talked a lot of things about police
i might have said that it wasn't it
wasn't you arguing europeans it was you
agreeing with john i was arguing john's
opinion without me even being involved
step aside john i got this
i got your back bro
i hope john appreciate it
i did i did uh john i'm fighting the
good fight john i'm fighting the [ __ ]
good fight he's got his boxing gloves on
for you man like he's fighting back
oh my god it's also that thing where
like i have said so much stuff in my
years of being online yeah that i have
forgotten a good chunk of any jokes or
anything i've made and i've had those
awkward moments where someone will make
a uh will reference a video of mine yeah
from like five
or years ago and i'll be like
what did you
say like i said they said the thing and
i was like
no the worst is when they ask you to say
it
being like i love this video that you
made can you say that one line and i was
like i know
from a let's play from like six years
ago like say that one thing you said in
corpse party episode 42 and i was like
uh
remind me how it goes again that's oddly
specific why would someone ask you that
i've had that
last year i mean i've made over a
thousand videos or like i don't remember
every single one i made yeah it's it's
gotten like it's been extrapolated even
[ __ ] more with trash taste now oh
yeah well i will get comments or i'll
get like people i'm so excited to like
have people bring up my opinions that i
totally forgot
because i've had conversation with
people i've met here um who obviously
watched trash taste and they were like
i'm like remember and they say to me
remember when you said this and i'm just
like did i say that
i mean that kind of sounds like
something i said uh i don't remember
when i said it but uh like like the
bleach video i'm just going to assume
that you're right and i did say that so
let's just let's just entertain this
idea
if you meet me in a convention
and he said oh you said this what's your
opinion about it i'm probably just going
to entertain that idea regardless of
whether i said it or not
let's talk about that
i love conventions so much man this is
my like weekly reminder that i missed
conventions god i missed conventions so
much
i'm hoping out of hope that we will this
year be the year this year be the year
i'm all right i'm playing the rest of
the year we finally get to go to
convention let's find out yeah one day